welcome back to cbs saturday morning we
begin this half hour with pope francis's
plea for forgiveness
on friday the pope concluded his six-day
visit to canada with a stop in a remote
territory near the arctic circle
the pope has spent much of his visit
apologizing for the catholic church's
role in abuses committed against
indigenous children over the course of
more than a century the pope arrived
back in rome this morning chris livesay
traveled with him during his trip
through canada good morning chris
good morning it was a historic visit for
pope francis apologizing repeatedly for
the abuse of indigenous children inside
catholic run boarding schools now gone
was the traditional celebration that
usually greets a pope on such visits
replaced by the very expressions of
culture the church once sought to erase
it was a moment that crystallized the
pope's penitential trip traditionally in
honor by chiefs four chiefs one that
seemed to say we accept your apology
i've come to your native lands to tell
you in person that i'm pained he said
and to beg god for forgiveness from the
late 1800s to 1997 more than 150 000
indigenous children were taken from
their families to attend residential
boarding schools the goal to forcibly
assimilate them and make them christian
often violently punishing them for
speaking their native language and
cutting the long hair so significant to
their culture i've come to cry with you
he said
but of canada's more than 1.6 million
indigenous people not everyone is
cheering richard greene spent nine years
at a residential boarding school when
you removed a child from the parents and
from the community
and
[Music]
get them to lose all their
their identity their language
i think that's a that's a genocide
a powerful word that was present in
canada's own truth and reconciliation
report but absent from the pope's
speeches
also missing an acknowledgment that the
abuse was systemic inside the catholic
church and not just the fault of a few
bad apples but the pontiff did call for
further investigation and even
apologized for pre-sex abuse which
plagued canada's residential schools now
that the pope has finally come after
decades of campaigning for an apology
the time has come for the indigenous
community to accept it says phil
fontaine the former chief of the
national assembly of first nations and a
survivor of boarding school abuse
credited with first bringing this issue
to international attention at some point
if we are serious about healing and
reconciliation
that cannot happen
unless we are prepared to forgive
now aboard the papal plane that just
returned here to rome pope francis was
asked why he didn't use the word
genocide his answer it just didn't come
to mind but as i was apologizing what i
described was just that
genocide jeff
chris livesay in rome thank you very
much